sure we want to go to all the touristy
things but we can't look like tourists I
[Music]
got a pack an outfits you know what if
we get invited to some VIP event do you
think we'll go on a picnic while we're
there I like that shirt but you always
complain that you look like a carpenter
in it I'm I'm nervous you know I have a
pair of client whose do you want a home
am i travellish and my travel deodorant
my travel razor where's my Purell oh I
have Purell not my travel Purell Purell
yeah do you have any Purell I need some
more pure out maybe you taking selfies
we're not gonna get to the airport on
time delete that I look awful Chris
you've got to roll everything if you
wanted all the fits having a second
suitcase in case of your shopping Chris
you're four thousand dollars in debt but
I mean if we see something you have to
have you have to get a tie we're on
vacation
okay one time one time oh my god what if
we like both fall in love over there
what if we just moved into that
apartment I found some wives rich wives
look at how bad news hold you I want a
pug I don't think I have enough room for
a blow dryer Chris be heavier this is
proof you're not fat
right that's the nicest thing you could
have said to me it's usually freezing
man well everywhere is freezing I said
that you aren't fat I know but you you
said it but you made me think about it I
think I'm just in a sensitive place
right now oh my god this place is
perfect airplanes make me feel gross I
need to take a shower and do my hair and
mmediately there's so many pillows I'm
gonna bring both of these Chris
[Music]